Here we go.
>> Hello. How you doing?
>> Hi. We heard we could get some Dawa
instruction here.
>> Yeah. Which information?
>> How are you?
>> How you guys doing? Avery. Nice to meet
you.
>> English and Spanish.
>> Whatever information you like.
>> The Qurans.
>> Yeah.
>> These are free.
>> Yes. Free.
>> Okay. I got it in different languages.
That's good.
>> Yeah. We have Spanish, Chinese, Bengali.
>> H. Okay. Nice.
>> You know what? Do you know what
translation this is?
>> Uh,
>> I can open it, right?
>> Yeah, I can open it and and take it with
take it to your home.
>> This one is the English right here.
>> This is the English.
>> This one's English. Okay. For sure.
>> All the cameras. But the one thing I
will tell you that we're not here for
debate. I know there this gentleman
tried last couple of days and I told him
very clearly that we're not here for
debate. Uh if you want to take something
go ahead. If you want to debate that's
fine but you know this is if you think
this is a debate cuz we try last couple
days I told myself he's not it.
>> No we don't have the debate.
>> Okay.
>> Could we ask questions?
>> No. Whatever you need information.
>> No questions.
>> No question.
>> Just give me your information.
>> We're just trying to see what
translation this is.
>> Sure.
>> Do you guys have a track on on Jesus?
>> Do you guys have a track on Jesus
information on like what the cross says
about Jesus?
>> Thank you.
Jesus a prophet of God.
[Music]
>> Does this teach that Jesus is like you
believe Jesus was a Muslim? A Muslim
prophet.
>> Jesus is a prophet.
>> Okay.
>> That's what we prophet. Yes.
>> So not a Muslim particularly.
>> He's a prophet. All
>> every prophet is a Muslim. That's what
we do. Muslim means someone who submits
themselves to God.
>> Okay.
>> So we believe that God sent every
prophet all the prophets and all the
prophets taught the same message which
is to submit to God.
>> Yeah.
>> So whoever submits themselves to God is
a Muslim.
>> Okay.
>> By the definition of what Muslim is.
>> Would you say that uh that that's more
of a generic term or is that
specifically about like the God that's
revealed within Islam? You know cuz cuz
like
>> we don't think that There are different
kinds of God.
>> Okay.
>> So, like I said, the God the creator
>> Yeah.
>> He sent prophets and messengers in every
nation.
>> Yeah.
>> And all of those prophets and messengers
came with the same message
>> which is submit yourself to God. That's
>> So, so like with regards to this cuz I
understand what you're saying as far as
the language goes as a Muslim.
>> Let's say I I believe in one God. I
believe in one creator. Um I submit my
will to him, right? But but in this but
in the same thing, right? But in this in
this instance, I believe that like the
God that I'm referring to, the creator
of all things, I'm referring to like a
statute that I have. Would I still if I
submit to that alone and believe that's
the creator of all things, would I still
count to be a Muslim?
>> I'm very uncomfortable with these
gentlemen here and
and like I understand you guys are
probably from the same, you know, I
don't I don't know. I just met him
today.
>> That's why here's the thing. I'm being
very honest with you.
last two days we've literally been
harassed
>> by him.
>> We're being nice.
>> Yeah.
>> So So So that's why I I'm very
uncomfortable taking, you know, getting
into a debate, but like I said, we're
not here to leave.
>> Yeah. Like
as you see, I'm not if if one of us gets
mean, then we're
>> Yeah. Just we we like talking about
these type of things. It's not
>> Okay. So what was your question again?
>> About so about the you know how you
define what it means to be a Muslim
submitting to one God, the one creator.
I was asking if I believed in one one
creator, one God. I believe I submit to
that God. But the God that I'm talking
about is a statute that I prostrate to.
>> Well, the thing is if God sent a certain
guidance
>> and a individual
they
>> if they follow that guidance
>> then they are following God.
>> Okay.
>> If they take if they do the same thing
not following the guidance of God and
they're not really following the
guidance.
>> Exactly. That that makes sense to me. So
I would say that being a Muslim it's
it's not as simple as submit to one God,
believe in one God, and then you're
Muslim. But there's a particular
guidance you have to follow, right?
There's a
>> isn't that like anything else, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah, that makes sense.
>> Like anything else in life, right? Like
>> if you if you if you work like let's say
you you have a 9 toive job
>> and you have you have certain task that
you need to complete
>> and your boss is not breathing over your
shoulder all the time,
>> right? But you cannot say okay you know
I finished my job on Monday morning I'm
not going to come rest of the week you
can't just make up your own so you got
to follow the certain rules that's like
everything else
>> so so with that being said then in
regards to within Islam there's a
particular guidance right Allah has a
particular identity he has qualities
that are specific to him that separates
him from any of these false gods of
these false ideologies right how would
you demonstrate that Jesus followed the
guidance of Allah like the guidance that
we find in Islam that qual qualifies him
to be a Muslim.
>> So
the way we see things is we see things
through the lens of Islam,
>> right? Quran says that Jesus was a
prophet of God. So that is that's what
we believe. God said so we believe Quran
is a word of God.
>> Yeah.
>> And whatever Quran says he is to be to
the truth. That's what we believe. So
Quran says Jesus used to worship God.
>> So he you know Jesus was a prophet of
God. So we do
>> so like we don't end up take a step back
look at the history of Jesus or whatever
>> to to make sure whether he was actually
did it or not.
>> Quran say he's a prophet of God. Yes,
he's a prophet of God. Moses is a
prophet of God. Yes, he's a prophet of
God
>> for us. That's that's what surprised.
>> I understand.
>> So I'll give you one last thing on this
topic. For example, in the Christian
Bible,
>> right?
>> Like we don't go into this whole thing.
What's a Bible? What's not?
>> Quran says that there's a book that was
revealed to Jesus.
which is sufficient for us. You know
what I'm saying?
>> It's sufficient for us that there was a
book delivered to Jesus.
>> Yeah.
>> So So this you said a lot of important
things, brother. So with this being
said, like obviously as Christians, we
we have the gospel, right? And like you
said, the Quran says the book was
revealed. Um Jesus came preaching the
gospel, right? And the Quran confirms
the gospel. The thing is is that when we
read the gospel, we see that Jesus
followed a different guidance than what
we see in Islam. like you know obviously
like Allah doesn't begin nor is he
begotten right he has no children that's
like blasphemous to say but Jesus goes
around teaching that he's the son of God
in the gospel and that he's the only way
to salvation right this is in the gospel
and so we see that Jesus the guidance
that he's coming with is completely
opposite of what we see from the Quran
so when I hear you say that okay like
Jesus was a Muslim to me that sounds
impossible just theologically based on
the type of guidance he was following
following. You understand my position?
>> I I mean I think I do.
>> Uh
>> so from the gospel that you're talking
about, right?
>> Yes.
>> The way that Jesus taught it seems
different than
>> Yeah. It's like contradicting.
>> So I don't as a Muslim I don't go into
looking at what the gospel has to say,
what the practice of Jesus was.
>> Okay.
>> Like it is as simple for me as does the
Quran say that Jesus was a prophet of
God?
>> Yes, he says. Wouldn't you have to
verify that though? Like if you're the
>> Quran is what my what what I write. You
see what I'm saying? For me, Quran is a
message. I don't I don't like I said
with the historical thing, I don't go
back and check.
>> That's that's important though. Like you
got
>> enough to me like because because with
the Islam literally means to submit
oneself to God.
>> Yeah.
>> So if I submitted myself to God, I don't
need to verify my
>> I don't need to verify what God said by
looking at something else.
>> My thing is
>> cuz then I'm not really believing what
God is saying, right? No, not
necessarily. Cuz because I I get what
you're saying. You have full faith in
what the Quran says. I I tr I understand
your position. My thing is that the the
Quran gives verification on what on why
we should believe it. And one of the
things is to go check the previous
scriptures. We can read about the
previous prophets and we can see that
the the Quran is in line with them. And
so like B like for example there's one
example in chapter 10 vers 94 where
Allah says to Muhammad if you're in
doubt about that which we have revealed
to you then go and ask those who have
been reading the scripture before you
the truth has come to you from your Lord
so be not of those who doubt. So this is
an example of if not saying that
Muhammad did doubt but if he did
hypothetical if you did doubt this is
what you can do go check with the
previous scriptures and that'll clear up
any doubts. So the Quran uses the
previous scriptures as a verifier, you
know. So like I say, if you're saying
you as a Muslim, you don't need to do
that. At least as a Christian who's
testing this, like, okay, I'm hearing
about it. I'm reading the Quran. Okay.
It gives me a a a way to test to see if
the Quran's valid.
>> Go for it.
>> Yeah. So if I if I do that and I see
that it contradicts what Jesus says, am
I fair to judge that the Quran is false?
>> You're fair. You you you are in charge
of your own opinion. 100%. Right. No,
not not opinion but like just
>> no no you again you are entitled to your
own view whatever you there's a version
of one that's there's no compulsion in
religion right God doesn't God didn't
send me to force you into believer
whatever you don't believe right yeah
you you're free to do whatever you want
to
>> so how how do you then reconcile this
this issue in the Quran
>> I already mentioned I already mentioned
Quran's whatever Quran says is enough
for me
>> so if it says the gospel is true is that
enough for you
>> Quran says whatever the book was
revealed to Jesus
>> that gospel
>> it doesn't say it doesn't say gospel it
says in jail
>> yeah that's the gospel
>> so what again whatever the Quran says
>> I believe if the Quran says in jail is
the true
>> cuz inj was revealed to Jesus was true
then I believe in it
>> so then you believe that Jesus is the
son of god who came died on the cross
>> no
>> that's that's the dilemma so like
>> the Quran is very explicit about saying
that Quran is very explicit about saying
that Jesus is not the son of god
>> I know that this is my point brother my
point is is that look even what you're
saying you're saying you believe what
the Quran says. Period. That's it.
That's all. Right. I'm I'm presenting
that the Quran says the gospel is true.
And then
>> saying in Jew is true, right? So the the
the in the gospel that exists today,
>> there's a whole debate about this which
I'm not interested in getting in at all
is whether the gospel today is the same
as in
>> right. So for me that's irrelevant.
>> Oh, that's huge.
>> That's very relevant. Cuz look look
brother, if if it's not the if it's if
if it's not the angel, then now we have
this uh this book that the Quran is
telling Christians to use and judge by
that we don't even know if we have or
not. And so but then Allah condemns the
Christians for turning away from the
gospel that they don't have. That that's
that's tough for us.
>> I'm not going to make a judgment on what
God has to do with Christians or not.
>> No, no, he already told us.
>> No. Okay. No, but my point is as a
Muslim, it is sufficient for me what God
said in the Quran.
>> Yeah.
>> So I don't have to worry about what was
sent to Jesus or what cuz Jesus cuz
whenever a people comes after a nation
after after a prophet, excuse me.
Whenever a people comes after a prophet,
that prophet is the prophet of those
people. So whoever whoever came the
people that came between Jesus and
Muhammad they were subjected they are
prophets was Jesus. Whoever came so
whoever came after Muhammad you me and
everybody else the prophet that God sent
to us all is Muhammad. That's what we
believe.
>> So do you believe that the Jews and Oh
go you off.
>> That's okay. So, so I don't need to go
back and find where the true gospel is
or true in Jill is to verify if God is
saying true or not.
>> So
>> for me it's sufficient that God said I
revealed in Jill
>> to Jesus who was a prophet of God and
that's sufficient. So the big issue here
is that if you're saying that's
sufficient for you, the Quran doesn't.
Because the Quran, for example, for the
Jews and Christians, if you go to
chapter 4:47,
it tells the Jews and the Christians,
the people of the book, it says, "Say,
oh people of the book, believe in what I
have we have sent down to you,
confirming that which is already with
you." Right? Confirming that which is
already with you.
>> Let me just read it in the Quran they're
putting out. So it says, "Oh you who
have been given the scripture, believe
in what we have revealed." It says to
Muhammad, they put in parenthesis cuz
it's not there. Revealed confirming what
is already with you. So talking about
you who've been given the scripture,
believe in what we've revealed to
Muhammad or the Quran. Why should we
believe in that? Because it's confirming
what is already with you. So it's it's
basically think what God loic is saying.
So you have your reasons for believing
in the Quran and you're saying that's
sufficient. But the Quran also tells us
why we should believe the Quran. It's
giving a it's giving a message to
Christians and Jews and it's saying you
Christians and Jews should also believe
in Muhammad and the Quran. And we say
why should we believe in Muhammad and
the Quran? But the reason the reason
that Jews and Christians are supposed to
believe in Muhammad and the Quran is
that it's confirming what is already
with us. And so we look at what we have
with us and God loves to explain how it
doesn't seem to line up because what's
with us says that Jesus is the son of
God. He died on the cross. He rose from
the dead. And that doesn't line up with
the Quran. So that's that's basically
the main confusion we have here is this
this isn't this isn't about you. This is
about the Quran says why we're supposed
to believe in the Quran. And the reason
the main reason it gives for why we
should believe in Muhammad and the Quran
is that the Quran is affirming our
scriptures. and that our scriptures are
confirming Islam. So, we look at our
scriptures and we don't think they're
confirming Islam, which means we're
either just we're misinterpreting our
scriptures or it was a mistake to tell
us to go to our book to confirm
Muhammad.
>> All right? So,
just one thing I would tell you is this.
Look, you as a Christian person, are you
content with what you believe?
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Without a doubt.
>> Then you have no reason to look further.
>> Okay? So we shouldn't believe in Islam
if we're content.
>> If you're no 100% I'm telling you
because the thing is again there's no
forcing here. There's no like there's no
intellectual gymnastic that's going to
go here. If you yourself is content with
what you believe, right? If you yourself
is content with what you believe and you
don't think there is any like I mean you
think that's the that's the truth then
you know then you what you believe is
yours what I believe is mine.
That's where I'm going to leave it at
because, you know, like picking
different verses and the context, you
know, not knowing the context, right?
And the interpretation of it, I don't
want to get into this conversation
because I don't know what to tell you as
far as, you know, how to interpret that
verse. You know what I'm saying? So my
thing is that look if
what I I gave you the preface of how we
believe what we believe about Jesus or
about previous scriptures for us is
Quran is the latest edition of God's
revelation and the final final final
revelation of God. What the Quran says
is what God wants the humanity to know
after prophet M. Quran says I have sent
prophets and messengers previously and
with some of them I sent scriptures with
Jesus I sent the the injil with Moses I
send the Torah for us that's sufficient
because what God wants us to do is
follow the Quran right so now if
>> wait just he wants you to follow the
Quran or everyone
>> he wants everyone who came after prophet
Muhammad cuz cuz the prophet that was
sent to these people is prophet Muhammad
>> so you you want has to be Muslim then
>> of course cuz that's what we that's what
we believe is to be the truth. Now, if
you don't agree with that,
>> where should we judge by that?
>> If you don't believe in that, that's
completely fine, right?
>> So,
>> yeah. Yeah. Go. So, so because you were
just saying a little bit earlier that if
we're content, we should stay Christian.
I'm sorry.
>> You were just saying a little earlier
that if we're content, we should stay
Christian. But now,
>> well, I'm saying if you're content, then
there's like, you know, there there's no
like having a debate over this, right?
>> What What should we be? What what ought
we to do?
>> But, as I said, God would want you to
follow his last final revelation.
>> Gotcha. And that's why we are here.
We're giving you information so for
people to know what God wanted them to
follow. Now, if you don't want to follow
that because of whatever you feel is to
be the truth, teaches to their own,
right?
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. I think uh I agree that what what
you're saying about the uh about the
perspective of the Quran. To me, it
seems like To me, it seems like it's
saying uh Allah sent Moses and sent
revelation to Moses and there's a
revelation for Moses that was given for
the people around Moses, but Moses is
prophesying other prophets who are to
come after him and then other prophets
come after him. And then Jesus comes and
then Jesus, he confirms Moses, but he's
also pointing to someone else who's
coming. And then Muhammad comes and he
said he's confirming Jesus and Moses and
we're reading we're reading these
passages um like he quoted surah 4 which
says that the reason the people of the
book shouldn't believe in Muhammad and
the Quran is because Muhammad and the
Quran are confirming the scriptures that
we have. And so it looks like our
scriptures are confirming him. He's
confirming our scriptures. And so that
seems to be the Islamic perspective that
there are all these revelations given to
Allah to different groups and they're
all confirming each other. And so as a
Muslim, you would say, okay, I believe
in I believe in uh in in these previous
revelations. And what what we're kind of
pointing out is it's not just it's not
just surah 4:47, it's it's 241, it's
289, it's 291, it's 297, it's 21101,
it's 2121. He says his the main argument
there are two main arguments that Allah
gives to Christians to say why we should
also believe because you're you're
saying you're saying that people after
Muhammad are supposed to believe in
Muhammad. I believe you're right
according to the Quran that we're all
supposed to believe in Muhammad. All
people in the book supposed to believe
in Muhammad and if we reject him then
we're kind of in trouble. But the two
reasons that the Quran gives for why we
should believe in Muhammad are one that
it's confirming our scriptures and two
that we find Muhammad mentioned in our
scriptures. So we go to our the point is
we go to our scriptures and the main
argument that Allah gives is that since
he's confirming our scriptures we should
believe in Muhammad but we go to our
scriptures and they don't line up with
Islam. So that argument seems to fail.
And then if we go to our scriptures and
we read Jesus died on the cross for
sins, he rose from the dead. He's Lord.
is the son of God. We read that. Then if
that's true and we're judging by our
scriptures, then it would seem like we
have to reject Muhammad. So the main two
arguments that Allah gives in this book
for why we should believe in Muhammad.
They don't they don't work. They don't
work. It's like it's like if I said the
main reason you should believe in me is
because if you go over there, there's
going to be a sign. It's going to say
believe in believe in David. He's a true
prophet. You go over there and it says
don't believe in David. He's he's a
liar. That that would be kind of what
the situation we're in. is saying
believe in Muhammad because of what's in
your books. We go to our books and it's
like they're saying don't believe in
Muhammad. And so that's kind of the
confusion like we we don't if that's the
main reasons then we have to reject the
main reason.
>> I don't have sufficient knowledge to you
know like to answer you.
>> Do do you understand the the dilemma
though?
>> I think I understand the dilemma.
>> Yeah.
>> But uh like I said I don't have the
sufficient knowledge to kind of you know
>> Yeah. So, so like not notice we're not
we're not coming from a place where
we're rejecting the Quran out of our
subjective belief in like we're
Christians if you can't tell already,
but you know, we're we're Christians.
So, whatever disagrees with
Christianity, we're just going to reject
outright. No, like we we've read the the
Quran. We've seen the claims that it
made, right? And we're testing it. And
so,
>> I see you.
>> Oh, I see.
By putting
>> makes a ninja
>> by putting the Quran to the test by what
it says, we're seeing that the Quran
falls short objectively, not not based
on our opinion, but just based on what
the Quran says itself and we test out
what it says that oh find Muhammad in
those scriptures. If we don't find
Muhammad in the scriptures, the Quran
made a false claim. Oh, the Quran is in
line with the previous scriptures. If
it's not in line with the previous
scriptures, the Quran's making a false
claim. So that that's the position we're
coming from. And of course if if our
scriptures have been corrupted like it
was a different jail why why doesn't
Allah say anywhere? Why does he keep
telling Christians judge by the gospel
standur within the same Christian world
there's difference of opinion what what
the true Bible is right like again like
it's not something that
>> it's not a mystery or it's not like a
claim that Muslims are making right
>> within the Christian there's no
confusion there's a lot of difference
but there's no gospel
>> not about the core of the gospel and
what the actual Christian scriptures are
there's difference about how to
interpret certain things but there still
is agreement on what the canon and what
the main books are of the scriptures
Anyway, so I mean like I said, I don't
have sufficient knowledge to
>> uh cater to your, you know,
>> No, that's that's good because lots of
people will try to make stuff up if they
don't know. So I I respect I respect I
haven't really studied that. That's what
I say when people are saying I look I
haven't studied that. I I don't know. So
if you want me to study it, I'll I'll
I'll look into it and get back to you.
So I respect that. Um just just I had
one more just one more thing there.
there's as far as what we were saying
about um we're not just like dogmatic
that someone can't be um speaking the
truth or something like that because um
as I'm sure you know when Muhammad first
started receiving revelations he went to
his wife and her cousin Waka who's
supposedly a Christian of some kind we
don't we don't know a lot about him but
Waka heard what he was heard what the
first couple of verses that Muhammad was
receiving and Waka who was a Christian
of some kind said hey I believe I
believe you're getting a revelation now.
I believe you're getting a revelation,
which I might have thought the same
thing because you're in the middle of a
bunch of polytheists and pagans and this
guy comes out saying there's only one
God and we have to believe in Moses and
we have to believe in Jesus. And if I
were there, I'd be like maybe this maybe
this guy is getting revelations. Maybe
this guy is getting revelation. So I if
I were in Waka's position, I might have
said
>> this guy might be getting true
revelations here. So, we wouldn't be
opposed to somebody, especially in like
some environment where they they don't
have creatures coming from other other
places enough and stuff like that. If if
God wanted to raise up a prophet to
speak to them, uh I wouldn't have a
problem with it. But Muhammad kept
receiving revelations. And again, he
eventually gave reasons why everyone
should believe in him. And if it were
some other reason where we looked at it
and said, "Oh, wow. This is a really
good point. This lines up with what we
with what we believe." That might be
interesting. That might be making us
think maybe we should believe in him.
But when we look at his main reasons for
believing and they just they don't line
up when we go and investigate him. Uh
it's kind of an issue. But um so yeah,
we think that's a serious issue. But
yeah, we we'll uh we we we respect the
you haven't looked into it. That's very
respectful.
>> Yeah, we appreciate. Can we shake your
hand?
>> Yeah, absolutely.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It was very nice to meet you
guys.
>> For sure.
>> I said I could take a couple of these,
right?
>> Sure. Don't worry.
>> Yeah. Take care, guys. Thanks for this
friendly like you. I'll be nice.